vor dem internationalen gerichtshof gab
es gestern eine erste anhörung zum
russischen überfall auf die ukraine kiew
hatte einen entsprechenden eilantrag
gestellt russland allerdings blieb der
anhörungen fern also kriegsverbrechen
völkermord diese vorwürfe stehen im raum
vladimir putin ein kriegsverbrecher mit
dem angriff russischer truppen plant
putin aus sicht der ukraine einen
völkermord jetzt verhandelt der
internationale gerichtshof in den haag
denn um einen kriegsverbrecher vor
gericht zu bringen braucht es vor allem
eins beweisen diese bilder zeigen putins
blutige angriffe menschen die wegen ihm
gestorben sind
streubomben
der angriff auf die ukrainische
atomanlage sabres jahr
oder schüsse von russischen soldaten auf
zivilisten passiert in der ukrainischen
stadt
all das zeigt wie brutal und skrupellos
russland diesen krieg in wirklichkeit
führt
die usa hat davor gewarnt dass russland
die zivilbevölkerung angreifen wird die
nato berichtet dass russland verbotene
streubomben einsetzt glauben sie
russland vergeht schwere
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine
ich denke wir brauchen eine eingehende
untersuchung dieser frage wir müssen den
sachverhalt ordentlich klären so dass es
keine zweifel daran gibt alles was sie
gerade beschrieben haben muss ordentlich
geprüft und untersucht werden er hasst
wie luchs internet und
eine eingehende untersuchung die der
internationale gerichtshof jetzt
vornimmt der ukrainische vertreter ist
bei der anhörung russland verweigert die
teilnahme sie sind hier nicht vor
gericht erschienen sind auf dem
schlachtfeld und führen einen blutigen
krieg gegen mein land die ukraine hat
eine andere position in der ukraine wird
das völkerrecht
aber könnte russland seine aggression
rechtfertigen wenn nicht hier und
russland sagt giesa krieg wird geführt
um einen genozid zu verhindern nicht
durchführt sondern
russische militärs die die
menschenrechte mit füßen
getreten und einigen durch der
gerichtshof für sein urteil so schnell
wie möglich treffen